So let's discuss the performance
of multi-threading and
how can it be better than simply
running things one at a time.
So if we have a processor with
no multi-threading support,
then this is how to threads might run.
These are cycles going
in this direction, so
each notch here is a cycle.
And we have four instructions
that can execute in this cycle.
So this is what might happen.
A green thread might be using this,
and this slot in this cycle.
And the other two issue slots are not
used because the processor has no
ready instructions to dispatch
to execution in this cycle.
Let's say there is a data dependence so
next cycle one instruction can wake up.
And then let's say that in the next
cycle we can have three instructions go,
but then let's say that all of
the instructions are now waiting for
something to happen.
So let's say for a few cycles
we don't get much happening.
Then, when it happens,
we get to execute, let's say, all four.
And then maybe another cycle with two,
et cetera.
So things can be like this, basically.
Much of the time we
are running with a less than
fully utilized processor pipeline.
Let's say that at this point
we get an interrupt, and
because there is another
thread that is read to run,
we now get many cycles of
the operating system doing its thing.
So it's also going to utilize
the pipeline in some way.
But it spends many cycles basically
figuring out which thread to run next.
Eventually decides that it's
going to be the blue thread and
begins executing instructions from
that thread on the processor.
So this is where we return
from the interrupt and
start executing a new thread.
Because let's say we have
these two threads ready to go.
So the blue thread in a similar
way will be using the processor.
Partially, let's say it
has a level one miss,
takes a while to get
the thing from level two.
Meanwhile, maybe it's able to
do something for a while, but
eventually runs out of things to do.
And then for example starts
doing something again, and
let's say this whole cycle is used.
So this is what might happen
in a processor with no
multi-threading support.
In that case really, the overhead that
you created by having to switch between
threads, is probably larger than the
gains we are getting from running them.
We we're better off just running
a single thread that does the work
of both of these threads.
So really, a single processor with no
multi-threading Is capable of doing this
with a good operating system,
not because it's better for
performance to break work into
multiple threads, but because we want
to be able to simultaneously run several
applications and make progress in them.
So that for example if you're playing
games and playing music at the same
time, we alternate between the game and
the music player.
Fast enough for you to not be able to
tell that they are really executing one
at a time on your one core.
If you have a chip multiprocessor,
we get to do something like this.
Now we have two cores, each of
which pretty much gets to execute.
One thread, so it's faster,
of course, than this, and
we can benefit truly from being able
to write multi-threaded programs.
But, you have to have two cores for
it, so the cost is about twice.
The cost of a single core here.
So with fine-grain multi-threading,
what we have is really one core,
but with separate sets of registers for
these threads and some scheduling logic.
With fine-grain multi-threading every
cycle we can switch between threads.
So what happens is,
the green thread gets exactly
same behavior in the first cycle.
In the second cycle we
do the blue thread.
So we get the behavior of
it's first cycle here.
Then we do some of the work
from the green thread again.
Then from the blue thread,
third cycle of the green thread,
third cycle of the blue thread.
And now, we would be running the green
thread except that there is nothing
to run there.
But what happens is the blue
thread has something to do.
So we spend another cycle
on the blue thread and
then the green thread is
still somewhere here.
There is nothing ready to run but
these operations are going on.
So the blue thread gets
one more cycle here.
At this point,
the blue thread has nothing to do, but
the green one now has something to do.
So, we end up doing the work of the
green thread and then for another cycle.
Then let's say neither of the threads
can do something, but then the blue
thread is able to do this because
it's been three cycles since here.
And then again, and as you can see,
we get done faster than here because we
are able to eliminate some of the cycles
where we were not able to do anything.
So, fine-grain multi-threading
benefits from the fact that when there
is a long period of idleness in one
thread, for example, due a cache miss,
you might be able to run still
instructions from the other thread.
And finally,
let's see what happens in SMT.
In SMT,
we are able to mix instructions from
different threads in the same cycle.
So what we will get is the.
Green one get's this.
The blue one also wants to use
the bottom slot, and let's say there
is a unit there, for example,
the load unit that you have to use here.
But we can still run
this in the same cycle.
Next cycle the green thread does this.
The blue one wants to now do this,
this, and this.
And we can let's say do this too.
But let's say there is a dependence from
this to this so we can only do this one.
Next cycle,
the green thread can do this, and
from the blue thread we can maybe
do this instruction, or maybe not.
So let's say we can't because
maybe this one depends also
on the one that we haven't done,
or the next one.
Now, however, there is some period
of idleness in the green thread, and
now the blue thread gets to make up for
missing out on some things, so
it's able to maybe do this, and
this dependent instruction.
And, at this point, the green thread
is ready to run something, so
we can choose whether to run
the green or the blue one.
Let's say that the green thread
has a higher priority, so
we always try to do instructions
from the green thread.
And only fill the gaps
with the blue ones.
Now we've done this,
next cycle we still do whatever
we can from the green thread.
We now can do this.
And now we only have
the blue thread left to do.
If the green thread has more
stuff to do, we can do this.
So as you can see, with SMT,
we get to populate unused slots
in what would otherwise be a full
speed execution of the green threads.
So that the blue thread
gets to make progress
while the green thread really
is not suffering for it.
And we can do that for
more than just two threads.
So for
example if we had four threads we might
be able to actually do another thread.
At a slightly slower pace than blue
while we are also doing this, so
with SMT what we are doing,
we are really using underutilized
issue slots in our out of
order super scaling processor.
The hardware cost to
do this is very small.
Our fetch stage needs to be slightly
more complicated to allow us to
fetch from one or the other PC.
And a register file needs to be slightly
more complicated because really there
are now two sets of
architectural registers.
But other than that the whole
complicated out of order engine
stays the same.
So let's say this is going to
cost us something like 5% of
the cost of a no
multi-threaded processor.
This here, again after we do
registry naming and everything else,
the process scheduler
stays just the same.
We just need to put instructions
from multiple threads
in the instruction window, so
that they could be scheduled from there.
And now also when we commit,
we have to figure out which instruction
belongs to which commit and so
on, so the cost is slightly larger than
fine grain, but still not very large.
Because again most of the complicated
preservation stations and
execution units, and everything else,
stays pretty much unmodified.
So this is going to have performance
that is maybe very, very close to a CMP.
Two threads here, two threads here maybe
making almost as much progress, but
at a very small fraction of this cost.